il n'y a pas que des jolies femmes sur
la croisette pendant le festival de
cannes il ya aussi de beaux hommes et le
plus beau de tous par et il était là cet
après midi pour présenter son premier
film en tant que réalisateur robert
redford nicole cornu langlois tout gamme
n'attendait son visage son sourire son
regard était partout et robert redford
enfin est arrivé venant de moscou pour
présenter son film ni l'agro et toute la
foule des professionnels n'a pu entrer
pour le voir entouré de ses acteurs et
devant les télévisions internationales
il nous a rassurés in imitera par regan
je m'intéresse beaucoup à la politique
mais je suis aussi très critique sur le
système politique
je préfère vraiment rester en dehors du
monde de l'arène politique pour de
multiples raisons
en bref pour répondre à votre question
je n'ai aucune intention de me présenter
comme candidat mais tout de même son
film est un peu politique puisqu'il nous
montre un village mexicain résistant
avec force et humour contre des
promoteurs immobiliers américains
j'ai de grandes affinités pour la
culture hispanique est pour moi
l'amérique latine tient une grande place
dans le monde et je pense que nous
devons être très vigilants sur ce qui
s'y passe ce sont nos voisins et je
pense que socialement et politiquement
c'est très important pour nous de
comprendre la culture latino-américaine
et je suis inquiet parce que nous ne
comprenons pas cette culture assez bien
pour entretenir des relations
diplomatiques correct avec eux voici
quelques raisons de mon film
et à part ce film quelles sont ses goûts
dans la vie arrivé dans mon travail de
cinéaste a concrétisé les images que
j'ai dans la tête c'est pour moi un
grand moment de satisfaction
mais la joie c'est aussi un super
coucher de soleil un champ de fleurs
sauvages
je peux continuer comme ça longtemps
mais je vais finir par vous ennuyer